السيف معقد حقًا
صحيح أنه مرخص كعمل فني.
غالبًا ما يكون الفشل في ذلك الوقت فشلًا كبيرًا وفشلًا لا يمكن إصلاحه.
[موسيقى]
على مدار أكثر من 1000 عام ، لم يغير السيف الياباني شكله أبدًا.
لم تتغير قيم وأهمية الموقف وتم تناقلها لفترة طويلة.
لا تقلق بشأن العمل
غير محدث
هناك توقيت لفتح روح المال في مكان كهذا
في ذللك الوقت
ما يقرب من 1000 درجة 300 درجة لتجعل مادة واحدة مظلمة
يتم شد إحدى المواد وتقطيعها إلى حوالي النصف ، والوجه هو أويتا.
eme
[موسيقى]
همم
أنا
نعم نعم نعم
اه اه اه اه
اه اه اه
همم
أنا
[موسيقى]
لقد سئمت جدا من مكان العمل
هذا العمل الملابس أيضا
معنى الأبيض محرج للغاية.
أيضًا ، لا تدع الصور تأتي
شاي
أنا أيضا أحاول ارتداء الملابس
[موسيقى]
في الأصل سيف ياباني
لا تقل مثل الهواء
أيضا ، أنا مريض أو مصاب
أشياء محظوظة للحماية من مثل هذه الأشياء
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من كونها عملية ، إلا أن جمالها لا يزال جذابًا لليابان.
أظن